oh good you got this video I'm glad
because it turns out that Facebook and
so on don't show us all our friends
posts they just show us some from some
of our friends that's why I ask for your
email address so we don't get cut off
now why might we be cut off well
sometimes I agree with conservatives and
social media companies are accused of
being biased against conservatives
against conservatives is against
conservatives are they all the companies
say our policies apply equally to
everyone for example you may not promote
violence but in Portland Oregon and Tifa
through things that journalists Andy no
because he criticized auntie FFA's
violence at one point they beat him
kicking him and punching him in the head
the attack left no with brain damage but
the attackers account is still up
linking to their website that justifies
the violence saying if you rally the
far-right to attack our city the
community will stop you however it can
so what does that tell you that there's
probably bias Glenn Beck runs a big
media operation called the blaze which
has millions of followers voices on the
right being silenced lately he's been
charging that social media companies
push a leftist agenda they manipulate
algorithms to reshape our world Beck has
not been banned but he says Facebook has
reduced his reach
you can post whatever you want we have a
little higher wall here for you well I'm
not a conservative I have noticed some
weird stuff going on my videos average
more than a million views but when I did
that one which included some criticism
of Facebook that video got less than
half as many views because Facebook
didn't show it to many people I can't
know that's secret for those who seek to
push hate today social media companies
are pressured to cut off anyone
spreading hate you have no place on our
platforms
now YouTube and Facebook say they even
demote content that almost violates
policies we do not allow hate groups on
Facebook overall they're shaping you as
an example of how they treat some groups
differently Beck points out that Twitter
and Facebook leave up an Tifa accounts
that promote violence in Austin they
were actually calling for the next phase
to have people be a paramilitary
operation that was up forever it's still
up it links to a manifesto calling for
their opponents to be beaten bloody
annihilated by contrast Beck says
conservative accounts are censored
merely for making fun of Democrats the
opportunity to something historic
remember the person who slowed down
Pelosi and they were outed outed
Facebook did say we dramatically reduced
its distribution the person who is in
charge happened to be one of the leaders
in Nancy Pelosi's office who had just
left Nancy Pelosi's office to go to work
well did that play a role they must hire
some Republicans they do but it's about
20% and they're not from top level
positions Zuckerberg met with 15
conservative leaders Facebook once
invited back and others to discuss
accusations that Facebook censors
conservative sitting with Zuckerberg who
is either not really running his company
is naive or a liar I don't know which
but I sat with him and he said why would
we do that why would we do that and okay
I agree with you I want to believe you
why would they tick off why would they
take off half of the people you know and
so I want to believe him
however your actions don't match Beck
was also unhappy with some of his fellow
conservatives there were some
conservatives that were there who said
well mark you can solve this by
basically having affirmative action
making sure that it for every liberal
you hire you hire I don't want that was
there any talk about saying look we're
just a
platform we shouldn't be doing any of
this we should just run everything that
nobody even brought to know and it
bothers me that there are so many
conservatives
that want more regulation we don't need
more regulation but it's human nature
whenever we see something we don't like
to say government must do something even
Beck fell prey to that
remember when Alexandria or Acacio
Cortez visited the border and claimed
she saw immigrants being told by CBP
officers to drink out of the toilet back
was so upset by that
he said she should be punished I would
like to prosecute anyone who is making
outrageous charges like this see what
prosecution of one of the five hundred
members of Congress who says nonsense
half of them say I mean John first of
all I speak five hours off acrid every
day
you're not eager to prosecute no court
says no no I'm glad he walked that back
truth comes out through argument open
debate the more social media companies
censor the less wheeler on at least some
platforms all speech should be free and
I'm glad Beck agreed with that you would
have them publish everything stop all
this censorship yes just let people say
whatever yep we can handle it
stop treating us like children